the planet screen lung almost a third of
the world's land surface is covered by
forests forests have huge ecological
value they protect biodiversity and
stabilize the climate they remove carbon
dioxide from the atmosphere trees absorb
the greenhouse gas and store the carbon
in there would at the same time they
release oxygen but since forests also
have an economic value some 13 million
hectares are lost each year the
equivalent of 40 football fields per
minute slash and burn practices release
carbon dioxide exploitation of Natural
Resources pays as does converting
forests into farmland the UN program red
plus has been working since 2007 to
reverse the trend by making preservation
of forests and not their destruction
financially viable the idea is to
provide financial compensation for
governments companies or farmers for
reforestation and to prevent destruction
but the problem is previous climate
summits failed to finalize an agreement
on funding and concrete implementation
of redd+ even defining a forest remains
controversial at least ten percent of an
area has to consist of tree tops
according to one interpretation this is
what it could look like or if sparsely
planted like this even the height of the
trees is debatable some say two meters
others insist on a minimum height of
five meters depending on the definition
smaller trees could then be easily
chopped even without UN agreement on red
plus further bilateral forest protection
measures continue to be taken like in
Germany with funding of more than 30
million euros local populations are
meant to benefit from the funds
sustainable forestry and projects such
as eco tourism are meant to improve
their income and at the same time
protect the forest